I always going to forget this, but let me figure it out. To
add a field, I was there was, where's that little click access guy?
>> So you can only see that when
you're actually in the app. from the end user
view. But right now we're in the setup. So,
we don't need a quick link to the setup.
>> Hm. Oh, custom fields, new field. I found it. Okay so I
want to add, I don't know, what should we track about our attendees?
>> Maybe their emails, so we can
send them the ticket?
>> Makes sense, Okay. so I bet there's an email field.
There is, nice work. That was nice work to Sales Force, just
>>
[LAUGH]
>> In general, thank you for giving me
the email field. Field Label, Email, I guess.
Okay, and again, not going to worry about this stuff.
Save. All
right, cool. We've got our field here just like we wanted.
>> Great.